hi everyone welcome to the Ubisoft
forward post show my name is Yousef
Nikita and this is Assassin's Creed
Valhalla we're gonna take a deep dive
into about 30 minutes of gameplay and
we're joined by a very special guest
here hey everyone this is Phillip bells
at all otherwise known as fizz
I am the quest director on Assassin's
Creed Valhalla
so fizz we're setting up here for what
looks like an epic encounter tell us
exactly what's going on here
yeah so here we're midway through the
the quest that were showing for you
before here we're looking at the assault
of burke castle so these are big moments
that usually sort of culminate at the
end of the story and so here a bar
viking raider is taking a group of
raiders and birds into burg castle to go
and take down ruied and his clan so who
exactly is ruied and why does a war sort
of want to pick a fight with them
basically ruied comes into play about
halfway through this story arc where at
the beginning of the art cut this is
something that that happens before bread
basically caused a lot of turmoil within
the territory and Oswalt who's the sort
of elderman to be to inherit this
territory needs your help to take him
down all's well having just been
defeated in a previous question so here
this is revenge but also accomplishing
your ultimate goal so as you're talking
we're seeing some of the combat of
Valhalla can you tell us a little bit
about the changes to combat the summer
oh we wanted to basically add a lot of
new mechanics to it so we added like
some dual wielding for the player like a
stun system in there and we really
needed to do this to sort of portray
that sort of the brutality that comes
with being a Viking
missandei chose sort of fits in
at the time in the character
possible
he lives shut your ass tweets by here a
war has taken her entire army through
the assault and finally it's revealed
that or or elderman or ally Oswald is
still alive and ruied has some captive
to Jane's fighting over a filthy saxon
or son this swine is your price come and
get him so now that we've seen that
Oswald is alive we have ruined within
our sights what's the next step here so
the next move for a var is to finally
face off against ridden she has her
allies they can take care of the rest of
the army now it's time to go one-on-one
against true it in one of our boss
battles are
and it's worth pointing out actually
that here what we're showing is the
player going and facing off against
ruied aggressively but you we tend to
always have a to support a 360 degree
approach in these things
so if Clara could have approached us a
little bit more stealthy and gotten at
least like a good critical hit on either
ruied or is wolf and so you can play
this a little bit more strategically if
that's your place not so we're not only
fighting ruied here but also his pet
wolf right you're one of my preferred
strategies is to eliminate the wolf
first just focus fire on him it takes at
least one opponent out of the combat now
ruied will have extra abilities that
come into play if you do eliminate his
wolf but I think having one opponent
less in the battlefield makes for a good
strategy in the whole
all your efforts only the cold taiga
leave behind the way
they should be wolf kissed a troll not
treated as equals we are better than
this and all of them do not drag me down
to the sewage swallowing you throw in
with these wastrels
these are give swine evil no he should
be tried before God a lawful assembly
alright so we've defeated ruin and we
freed Oswald what comes next
Oswald in this case prefers for rue it
to be kept alive and so you basically
have to choose are you gonna go against
his witches or to stay true to your
nature so we have this choice to make
but before we get into that I want to
rewind a little bit because we just did
this big grand assault but a boar
couldn't have done it alone she clearly
had to recruit some folks along the way
to get some troops get some allies so
let's actually rewind and see how we
went about first gathering those troops
right so when coming up to an assault
it's a game of numbers ie vork can go
into pretty much any location and be a
stealthy Viking eliminating some of the
assets which ultimately would be a
strategy you can do that and you'll have
some some of the ingredients or of the
assets there that will have been
sabotage but you still need a army so
here what we're seeing is a war going
around the countryside and raising what
we call aford which is the men and the
women of the territory who come up and
fight in the name of a king so here
a war is going around and try and
convince people to fight in the name of
Oswald to finally take down the
oppressor that is ruied defending you
would you not do the same what
Dorian defense of the last cars yeah so
she's really using like the the image
and like the the leadership that Elle's
will have what he meant to the people in
his name she's going to recruit these
people pretty words Dane but a minute
they wanted to have their own
battles deflate so we're told by this
reeve that there are troops there are
allies that he could add to our cause
but first we sort of need to do him a
favor is that right yeah so obviously
these people have been run down by ruied
and the impact he's had on the territory
so I think a lot of these people have
sort of lost hope and so you need to
show them that there is hope and so here
a var is basically helping them take
back one of their their prized locations
by taking a couple men and raiding a
nearby Township basically taking it back
to the people and showing that there's
there's a reason to continue fighting
and then get them on your side
when a Ford does this obviously you have
access to a full suite of ability so
again the improvements that we've done
to the flight system you have some
brutal axe throwing in there you have
archery or like range combat abilities
in there as well so really again like
depending on what your play style is you
can customize your loadout and go in
there how you wish
Faye's we just saw this giant pulse go
out what exactly was that so that is
actually this is what we called the Odin
site the inside is basically our
interpretation of the Eagle vision from
previous games and we thought it was
good to just sort of bring that back
it's basically a horse intuition it's
how she perceives the world when Blair
uses that you can it'll highlight
basically interactive objects like
things that will bring her an advantage
so we'll have arrows come like health
consumables that are in there so it
really is like a good way of sort of
understanding the world and showing you
like things that you can go and touch
yeah I mean speaking of things we can
touch we just picked up this awesome new
weapon it's something we wanted to play
with on Assassin's Creed Phil Halle
where we have fewer weapons in the game
but you can invest in them more so they
become your weapon and so depending what
your preferred playstyle is or your
preferred weapon type then you can go
and choose I'm gonna I'm gonna fight
with this weapon and invest heavily into
that not only are we looting weapons but
we see something here called The Book of
Knowledge he tell us a little bit more
about that the unlock skills for the
players so here you can see the Valkyrie
die that has just been unlocked we have
these spread out throughout the world so
again to promote exploration and
discovery as you travel through the
world you explore locations you can find
these books that will add abilities that
you can go and invest in put into your
loadout then go into the different
locations with the different quests in
the game and use though depending on
what your playstyle is now we've
recaptured this village we've secured
more troops for our assault let's jump
back now and figure out what we want to
do with Rouen
[Music]
the rightful king of East Anglia has
spared your life today
and so it will be compassion is a virtue
suited for anyone able including you
thank you
hey Lord decide to let him live ruied is
really angry about that being a Knorr
Viking being put to the death in battle
is your road to Valhalla so he was
basically denied access to Valhalla in
this situation obviously all these
decisions come into play later on in the
game so we have very difficult decisions
for the player to make we didn't want to
have easy decisions yeah you know when I
was playing I decided to listen to
Oswald and spare ruit's life but what
exactly is the relationship like between
a boar and all so the relationship
between a lure and Oswald is is it's an
alliance it's basically a VAR is
surrounded by territories that initially
getting into England are hostile towards
her and obviously if you want to set up
a new settlement you want to have make
sure that your neighbor is friendly so
if you're nice and Lea Oswald as demand
for the job we're putting him into a
position of power would help her soar
secure her territory so earlier on to
the territory a vork comes in here meets
Oswald the problems he had with Dredd
are sort of put to light and going
through the arc you basically help him
deal with red and and aligning basically
Danes with Saxons in one territory so
we've completed the assault we've got
our hands dirty with some combat taken
down ruied we have this big open region
of East Anglia so before we head off to
Oswald wedding what do you say we head
out have some fun and see what we can
get into in the open world that sounds
great
so we see a cat here with a speech
bubble above it and you best believe if
you let me talk to a cat I'm gonna talk
to okay yeah these are some of our
I suppose some of my favorite moments
actually in the game where we put in put
a whole bunch of events throughout the
territory and it sort of rewards again
exploration going around it's a it's a
chance for us also to sort of showcase a
different side of a war a lot of the
quests were to deal worth more with like
politics and warfare and this shows a
slightly more human nature to her so it
permitted us to explore that character a
little bit more so here basically like a
year you're trying to help a kid with
his cat and ultimately get that cat to
sort of join your crew as a cat Raider
you just said Cat Raider way too
casually you told me I could have a cat
Viking Raider on my long show that's
that's exactly what I'm telling you oh
my god yes so yes as you're riding
around the the rivers of England you
would see a cat basically walking around
your long ship keeping your Viking
raiders company of the Viking longship
we're seeing some gameplay here now you
talked a little bit about how that works
in functions in Valhalla yeah so
starting out on this project I think the
Viking longship is one of the the
biggest images that we all have when we
think about Vikings in our game and so
Vikings had this this awesome design for
launch ship they had a very shallow halt
so permitted them to go very far inland
very quickly and you could basically
disembark the Viking raiders like on
pretty much any shore we added that into
the game where you can basically sail up
to any location and then just decide to
disembark with your guys and raid a
location snoodles treasure get back in
the ship and then continue really a
sailing down the river to your next
opportunity so I know past Assassin's
Creed games allowed for songs and things
like that to be sung on ships will
Valhalla have a similar version of it
yeah so this is something we actually
wanted the the cruiser ship to become
like you're at your home away from home
so we added stories and songs into the
ship so basically as the player
it's going around you could decide to
have your skull sort of sing a song for
you as you row down the river but you
can also decide depending on who the
Raiders are in your ship to hear more
about their life so you can actually
queue up stories and they'll give you a
little bit more background who they are
so you get to know your your sort of
fighters as you're traveling around the
world which is a cool moment so here
we're seeing a bit of a different view
what exactly are we looking at we had
this on previous Assassin's where you
would like ride on your horse and you
could pull out have the rode the horse
sort of follow the track we have a
similar thing for the ship where you can
put up your sails
it's cruise control for the ship so you
can pull back taking the scenery listen
to some songs or some stories and just
take it all in
so you know speaking of Viking songs we
have an activity here that's not exactly
singing but kind of related right yeah
so here what we have is what we call
flighting which was an activity that
Norse people will partake in they would
like to have a battle of wits and and
sort of poetry where insults would be
thrown back and forth between each other
the idea was to try and have a good
insult but also to have a good rhythm
and a good rhyme in there so it's
basically a precursor to rap battles
here's the silver now begin
to all those whom I speak they say Ava
was a clod
then you're speaking to fools and their
knowledge is flawed well how exactly do
you go about being successful in one of
these trick behind a good flight
was to choose the right insult I didn't
find the right cadence and then trying
to find what rhymed the best I'm known
for my might
interesting interesting
silent whispers all claim that you're
terribly dense then you've clearly
missed hurt them my wit is immense oh
you looked out with that one well what a
surprise a bore of the Raven clan is a
true talent I'm shocked don't believe
everything you hear
unless it touches on my flighting then
he'd every word take the coin so now
that we've proven our sharp tongue and
wit I think it's time for a bit more
relaxing activity so we're fishing here
yeah that's it so we gave a boar a
fishing line so you can actually throw
out a line and go catch them fish this
is used basically to to play into our
new health loop where the player will
lose health and in the world and it
doesn't automatically generate it
regenerate like we would have in the
past so you actually have to go out and
get some some supplies so you'll find
mushrooms and some food that you can
gather but here like we you can also
catch them fish and consume that to
regain some health if we also some will
sometimes have it in in certain quests
so it's a good way to sort of chill out
on the side of the water and just again
take it all in
so this is what we call one of our
offering altars so the idea is that you
you find these around the world and you
make offerings to it and so it will take
like animal parts and stuff that you can
find throughout the world here what
you're seeing though is sort of like a
fancy version of it where as you do your
offering you get interrupted by some
some kids that basically come and steal
your stuff so it's just a way for us to
sort of showcase that like the systems
and activities in the world can sort of
play in with some some quests and some
little bit so it's our worry to sort of
dress up these moments and make it all
fit inside the whole experience yeah
this seems like a really sort of
unexpected turn for what I thought was
gonna be as kind of a simple interaction
yeah and it's really what we were trying
to do with these events today is to give
another dimension a war rather than just
you know the pure rawr Viking or the
politician because you can imagine at
some point that will hold if you're
always telling that that that version
the character so it lets us really go
into the death of who is a var what
motivates her how she can interact with
the world outside of warfare and
politics and it also showcases like a
different facet of the world at the same
time it's not only so it just widens the
breadth of the stories that we can tell
so who exactly are these two children
these are kids of East Anglia they are
going through tough times with whatever
route it's been doing to the territory
and so they're just here trying to
survive and and basically exploit the
people that are there to make offerings
it was kind of nice to see that a war
wasn't really necessarily upset at them
for stealing and you know after you talk
to them you have a choice of helping
them you can you know give them food
give money or you know maybe just say
hey good luck on your way and this is
something we also wanted to do a lot
like we so here we're doing an event we
do any quest as well but we want to do
give a lot of this agency into players
hands so that
they can sort of shape a voor a little
bit who she is or represents them a
little bit more and they can roleplay
that a little bit better and again it
just gives her like a little bit more
humanity and these in these moments
provide for small walkers
here large Walker a necklace yes it's a
st. Martin seal
you're welcome here anytime large Walker
you're one of us now visit us ok I will
take care now
small green walkers so I think a see
veterans might recognize this here but
what exactly is a war chasing down yeah
so here you're seeing it we're running
down one of our tattoo images so this is
challenging the player on free run
abilities but also for fans of the
series sort of pulling at their
heartstrings for some beloved features
so are we gonna be able to tattoo a
board yes by collecting these tattoos
you actually bring them to back tear
settlement and then you can customize
different body parts having different
tattoos everywhere so again another form
of expression and it's sort of to
represent that bulk that Viking culture
fizzing one of my favorite things when I
was just out there exploring East Anglia
was coming upon a house or building and
realizing that there was a chest inside
but that there was no easy way in and in
this case I saw all the doors were
barred but I knew that because there was
a chest in there there must have been
some way to get inside so I went around
the back and you know found a way in
yeah I'm glad you actually caught onto
that you're pointing at something that
we wanted to work on a lot on Valhalla
where we wanted the exploration to make
you feel smarter so we played a lot with
puzzle solving so making sure that every
house that you find sort of appeals you
like it draws your attention and then
when you want to come and explore it's
not it's not given to you you still have
to work for a little bit so it'll
challenge you on your observation skills
logic just trying to find how do I get
into this so we play a lot with level
design quest design to offer challenges
to players and you basically come out of
it like with a better feeling for the
exploration but you also get to see more
of a story behind in these two locations
which we've crafted so it gave us a
little bit more time to sort of slow
down the experience and
tell a different version of a story a
poor victim of someone's fury yeah I
mean speaking about exploration and just
finding things out in the world I was
just wandering and came across this
clearing and found this kind of morbid
alter yeah so this is this is one of our
bigger events that we we have scattered
in the world
so as a more explorers she can find
altars like this and by interacting with
them here it's a trap that's been set
for by by this character named Regan now
there's a bigger story behind all this
there's multiple steps to it later on so
this is one of the moments it permits us
to go into a slightly more mystical
realm and play with a boss fight that
has more magical abilities if we will
and basically have this awesome boss
fight in the middle of the swamps and so
here the abilities that you see Regan
using like are a little bit on the
mystical side of things what's happening
is Eve or at the beginning in that trap
is poison and so she starts sort of
loosening seeing the world and a sort of
different light and filter and so that
that's sort of what lets us go into this
this the the realm of the weird
so we just saw here that Regan belongs
to something called the daughters of
Leary yeah that's correct by finding the
other daughters you'll get a little bit
more backstory on who they are so we
don't want to spoil that too much but it
creates like a sort of greatest story
that is not on the main path in any way
but it's still very rich and adds to the
lore of this world and actually plays
into history so we just had a really
exciting really intense boss battle I
think it's time for something a little
bit more relaxing and calming now yeah
it's all here it's all about pacing
yourself with the highs and the lows so
here we have a low chill moment of what
we call building a cairn so Eve or as
she explores the world we'll find these
sort of meditative areas where you have
a pile of rocks that you could just
stack on one on top of another using
physics and I mean yeah the ultimate
goal is to try and get the highest pile
of rocks but really it's about taking in
the sights
relaxing taking a step back and and
built just building something together
we stacked stones into parents lease yes
think of this as a test of mind and
weight SEC that Karen stone was high and
wide into any shape you like I mean you
can spend as much time as you want
building these things making them size
you want as weird as you want I'm sure
like a lot of these stuff will end up on
the internet like people comparing
structures and the cool thing is that
once you've built it and you decide to
get out of it it sort of stays there and
so that's yours right and until the
moment where you come back and you want
to build a new one is it's sort of cool
that we were able to to give that to
players to express themselves at this
point in the demo we've explored East
Anglia
we've met some children we've broken
into a house we fought a boss we've
built a Karen I think now it's finally
time to go and head off to Oswald's
wedding yeah so this is the moment it's
all been building up to um by the moment
you get into the Therese Tory sort of
like mentioned by Oswald that he's
trying to
get married with this Dane lady and so
as you go through the arc that's sort of
like the underlying thread really it's
about ruied creating turmoil in the
territory and helping all sort of get
above that and and show that he's a good
leader and so you finally after going
through all of that arc finally get
these two together go through there
they're wet at their wedding and you're
invited to attend the ceremony and then
all the activities and fun times that
come afterwards
yeah as much as we've seen the brutal
side of England we nice to see the
joyous side of it as well
yeah and it's something we really wanted
to play on and in Valhalla
where being a Viking is not only about
being a Raider or warrior I mean there's
revelry there's feasting there's
partying that goes and like if if
someone knows how to party it's a Viking
and so here this is one of our
opportunities to sort of show that show
what a sort of Viking gathering is and
what's cool here is it's a it's a good
alliance of Norse culture with Saxon
culture sort of smashing those two
things together and building bridges
yeah I mean what's a wedding without
some drunk Archer right yeah so anything
can happen in a in a Viking event right
before yeah here here they just get
drunk some shoot some arrows challenge
steady old and ready yourself for the
wedding race the king and his bride
against oh my king
so here we see the decision I made this
bear really came back to bite us yeah
that that's the decision you made coming
back so as we said before all your
decisions have consequences and this is
a big one challenge
I accept your basically presented with
the option to sort of step in for Oswald
fight the fight for him or let him go
and fight his own fight yeah you know
personally I chose the fight myself
because I thought Ivar is the type of
person who likes the finish and a dead
King cannot keep his oath let me finish
this Cutlass is fine I'll play the wolf
kissed then hang you with your own
tongue this encounter would ruin differ
from our previous fight way so at this
point you've eliminated his wolf so it's
just him and so he he's angry at this
point and so he will start using his his
big gun abilities like fairly earlier on
in the fight so it's way more vicious
way faster there's less strategy he goes
literally swords blazing at you um and
so this is a fight to the death
[Music]
and of course here like this is a
decision you made to go and fight him
but there's multiple outcomes to this
scenario you could have left as well
fight his own fight and prove basically
his station as the rightful leader if
you had eliminated through it obviously
this would not have happened would have
been a slightly more joyous occasion but
ultimately in all scenarios you still
have an alliance with Oswald he's proven
to be the right leader for this
territory and to be a good Ally for you
I promised you an alliance now you have
it and one day I will need you to make
good on that alliance so we're about to
take off from the wedding but a board
decides it's a good idea to check up on
her friend thinner yeah so fin affinor
is probably one of the more recurring
characters in this arc you get to meet
him very wrong he's very endearing
character sort of used to have a Viking
life sort of misses it and going through
all these adventures together it's sort
of like lights that fire back and so
he's willing to join you in your raiders
so he's one of many Raiders that you'll
you'll encounter in the game and you can
sort of recruit bring back home and then
have them sort of join you on your
adventures on the longship he can tell
you these stories that were telling you
about you get to know a little bit more
about him so again it's a fun way to
sort of discover more about these
characters that you meet and bring him
along for adventures together together
I've gathered my things whoa folks we've
come to the end of our Assassin's Creed
and Valhalla playthrough fizz thank you
so much for joining us when and where
can people play it Assassin's Creed
Mahalo
we'll be out on Xbox series X and
PlayStation 5 and is coming to Xbox one
Playstation 4 PC and stadia on November
17th
Assassin's Creed Valhalla available
November 17th